hey guys welcome back to the channel and
today we're going to be talking about
the newest leak that's been floating
around reddit recently by a twitch
streamer and a Reddit user named I skies
you just have to check out his twitch
streams is very good at for honor very
popular member in the community very
good at tournament play as well should
definitely check him out when you have
the chance but this news week talks
about a new hero that has been leaked
alongside be Centurion and the ninja if
you did not see those two should
definitely check out that video that I
did post about the two new heroes they
do look very nice and I do believe that
they could be definitely added into this
game but the third character seems to be
a Highlander type of Viking character
now the only difference is that they
don't actually have the picture for him
in the bottom left they just have the
temporary icon as shown in the last
image with that we were given a couple
weeks ago he is a Gaelic warrior so I
deem might be in the Vikings he might
not someone didn't mention in the
comments below that this is going to be
a faction like an oddball faction where
it's basically a bunch of people to come
around the world like mercenaries they
don't have a specific team but they
fight together so that might be a very
big possibility the difference with this
is that doesn't really show with weapon
unlike the other two characters as the
centering in the ninja you can clearly
tell the weapon they're using and what
they look like this one seems like it's
more grayed out like it was supposed to
be like that like so that we couldn't
really tell or that's just how he looks
he does seem to be heavily padded arm or
very thick beard looks like he has a
bandana so let me know what you guys
think about this whether this is real or
not I don't really know to be honest I
was debating I'm making this video
because I thought this was like faker
than the other two but then I mean it
looks it looks like it could be in this
game so I decided to put this out for
all of you so I do hope you enjoyed this
video if you did like this if you did
like the video guys please be sure to
leave a like if you're new here then hit
the subscribe button we do tons of for
honor content on this channel guys so
don't worry about that I'll be coming
out of this video in the next couple
days haven't really decided what it is
but it'll definitely be out and I will
see you guys in the next one peace out
boys